it's Friday that must mean it's time for
G s news top-5 this is a little sister
wearing a Yoshi hat no it's not a
crossover this is definitely game spot
news and I'm definitely then I'm Jess
another free Pokemon is gonna be
available for Pokemon Sun and Moon
players who go through game stuff and
pick up a card and put it in they'll be
able to get stalazs all I salsa Liezel
for the first time today and basically
he looks like a sexy emo Johanna
okay what level is us allies all
available are we he's bad already so
he's gonna be level 50 he comes equipped
with a focus sash a one use item that
allows him to enjoy any attack that
would normally knock it out it also
knows fake out toxic sludge bomb and
flamethrower you can download them via
the mystery gift option using the free
code from Gamestop the distribution goes
until September 4 and right now you can
actually also get a rash tiny taboo
cocoa so I should go pick that one up as
well I'm gonna trade by this how else
would you describe certain Pokemon how
would you describe Pikachu that yellow
blob not what I was expecting
continuing my tradition of only talking
about the latest and greatest shooters
it's time for me to talk about player
unknowns battlegrounds so long Rainbow
six siege so on overwatch we don't want
you anymore
you dead to me the July updates finally
out even though it did come out in
August which is kind of sad because they
had to keep delaying this new update
that was that in first person servers
still a they tried to bring it to PTR
and it just wasn't stable enough for the
public test realm yes sir I had to be
pushed back again but as we say as of
yesterday it's finally out and
apparently really hard to play a
first-person not sure if you tried it
but uh yeah it turns out this again much
easier played in third-person but the
point of the first-person service is
everyone playing in first-person so it's
not just a choice it can make now it's
actually you can be assured that
everyone is playing with the
disadvantage of first-person Xbox
controller support has been added and
they're gonna continue updating it and
supporting it as a more update for all
around so if you wanna play with a
controller look at that ago maybe you
get a little taste of what its gonna be
like when it launches on Xbox one X like
this year there's also a bunch more
updates that are stuff like UI tweaks
new animations and they've also tweaked
the timing of how when it takes you to
loot things from corpses and stuff like
that because I don't know if they want
to do that rather than give you a mantle
and
no when you jump over stuff you just
like if there's two things I love in
this world it's good roll with no
clothes on and coloring in the roll with
no clothes on but until now I've not
been I've not been able to do that yeah
so this is a story I actually decided
not to cover earlier this week because I
thought it was silly but it's Friday and
that's what we do on Friday there is a
which is recalling book to make my long
interest short and as Dan mentioned it's
got a girl in the bath one is rated
adult although not sure whether that
means adult for the themes or adult for
like the difficulty because the coloring
it's a little hot I mean look when I was
in seventh grade in art class my teacher
told my parents that I should probably
pursue other skills that's how you ended
up here I don't know much about odd but
you know what your life and it seems
like what rocha lights is apples yes so
they've only showed off two drawings so
far I'm pretty sure Twitter might have
grabbed more of them but one of them is
grown in the bath and the other one is
girls trying to get Roche away from some
apples which is just a delightful
picture it's being published by Dark
Horse Comics it's gonna be out in
November first and I believe it's gonna
run you about 15 bucks and before we
finish up talking about the Witcher set
a project have also confirmed that
beginner update The Witcher 3 for Xbox
one X and ps4 price support yeah it's
really interesting because they
originally said no no we're not gonna do
that we want to focus on this side the
punk 2077 Inc went but now they have
just changed their mind apparently now
they're doing it so if you came for that
to happen yeah enjoy it Jesse what I've
been playing a heap of Pokemon go
recently hung way more than I think
everyone else who put the game down but
yeah it's it's got Legendary's now
that's really exciting so we would have
told you about that before
Otto Kerner came out for I haven't had a
chance to talk about that one news yet a
lacuna is my favorite Pokemon okay but
right now all the rage is Moltres
mantras is coming as of August 9 okay
you'll be able to pick up
Moltres in raid battles same as the two
other Legendary's to come before so
first you'll have to defeat the Pokemon
in the raid battle and then you'll have
a chance to catch it try to catch it
because I can tell you firsthand when
you defeat it and then you don't catch
it and it runs away it is heartbreaking
it is not only heartbreaking it's also
annoying for the person who did
successfully catch it as they're then
chewed out for an hour or two about how
it's unfair that they caught it and did
not catch it
so mulch is actually gonna be available
from August 7th I think I said 9th
before August 7th until August 14th
then on August 14th if you're an
electric type 1 type fan
Zapdos is gonna be legendary you can
pick up from right so you know keep your
eyes out if your cane there's also
apparently ho oh oh oh ho I think it's
oh ho oh yeah he's another bigger one on
the horizon um basically it's just fancy
birds legendary I it's beyond the
original generations others yeah I only
know the original hundred-fifty like
Togepi but yeah apparently he's on the
way so keep your eyes peeled if you're a
fan of Gen 2 but one day another Pokemon
carnies Niantic decided to cancel the
European live events they had organized
after thee you know so we put it lightly
debacle fire festival s debacle that was
there Pokemon go Fester's they attempted
to kick off in Chicago where a whole
bunch of players couldn't connects
couldn't like grab Pokemon uh and it's
not like they took it well either the
players know some people who travelled
quite far it seems the people were
pretty upset it was a huge event
everyone and gathered I think they had
thousands of people there who just
couldn't get online but they just kept
going with the show anyway telling
people make sure you catch those
pokemons
and audience members were chanting we
can't play so it's pretty much exactly
as French is you can imagine it being
new antic did apologize and offered
refunds and things like that but
hopefully next time they attempt
something like that I mean they make
sure that that's not gonna happen
hopefully yeah you know what I don't
like tin what's up calling
DLC expansions when it's actually the
other things working for you it seems
like Activision are working on destiny
too and making those expansions actually
legit expansions CEO Eric Hirschberg
said an earnings call the other day that
the expansions that are coming up for
destiny too are as important as the main
game - it's kind of as sustained to
maintain the audience that they're
building with destiny - yes they are a
little skeptical about that
I think it's nice to say hey they're
just as important also they cost you
another 50 bucks I think that's fair to
be skeptical especially after the
expansions that were in destiny one like
the first expansion I can't remember
which one it was it was but it was quite
small and yeah nothing and then there
was the second expansion that was
definitely median changed the game quite
substantially and added in lots of
things like character to the characters
in the game which was you know what
destiny one was calling out for so I'm
I'm cautiously optimistic about this one
obviously I'm gonna it's destiny I'm
gonna probably grab the expansion pass
anyway but also the the reason why
they're putting so much time and effort
into the expansions this time is that
they're trying to appeal to a broader
audience bringing it to PC they're
localizing it in more countries and also
teaming up with a blizzard and using
paddle map all the blizzard app which is
what it's now called to bring it to PC
is something that they're trying to you
know just just broaden the appeal of
destiny - yeah I mean I think the main
thing they wanted to do with the
expansions and add-on content is just
like keep people playing keep providing
new experiences new stuff for the story
stuff to do with the game and foster as
well this time which is why they're
getting a lot more studios to work on
stuff so definitely I feel like okay
this is might be another popular opinion
but destiny is in Australia or a hundred
dollar game in in America and that's not
the expansion that's just like a
standard triple-a release is $100 in
Australia and I feel like I kind of feel
like going which three on this one I
feel like waiting I feel like these kind
of publishers should provide a balance
of stuff that comes for free and money
and I feel like it might be airing a
little like 2 on the buy all that extra
stuff because it's super important and I
think it's a little harsh to be like oh
you want the full experience that's
gonna be a hundred and thirty dollars
yeah it's it's definitely something hard
to kind of sticks in my craw as well is
because it's destiny the games we played
with your friends yeah and all of a
sudden if your friends have this new
content that you can't play like it's
also also destined does a thing when
when the new content comes out it really
does feel like if you don't want to get
it you are punished by being held behind
and it's just kind of a if you want to
be part of the pack you've got to spend
that money and you're right here I think
for the super duper collector's edition
it comes with a season pass
actually the one that just comes with
the season
it's 150 bucks yeah and that's a lot of
money to be droping on a game that you
aren't too sure if you're gonna be
playing in the next series that is it
from us this week do you let us know
down in the comments thought you cared
about what stories do you like us to
cover each day we'd love to hear from
you you can catch us both on Twitter and
I hope you have a good weekend I do okay
Jesse what I've been playing a lot of
Pokemon go recently oh boy